[Music]
i'm moving i'm moving to los angeles
i am a laker i am i'm definitely a laker
i feel it
and uh i'm happy as hell to be one
i'm at a point now where i i know what
i'm here for and i'm just trying to use
you know my knowledge and use my
position of power to be able to
influence
for me to be a los angeles laker and
play inside staples center
to see all that purple and gold for us
to be able to um
you know play the game that we love i
mean it's a beautiful thing it's not
much more that you can ask for for me
personally being a basketball player i'm
chasing
that greatness that's always been my
goal since i got an nba right good
sorry for the interruption interrupt me
anytime with that number
23 lebron james
ever at home scorcher
i'd say he's really warm
and here he is he might fire one up
james lost it gets it back james
holding his left leg tried to stretch it
a little bit and then limped
back to the locker room lakers now
without lebron james
and lift off the court he hasn't missed
the game this season
how do you think this season will be
remembered for the lakers it's a lost
season
paul hurt himself grabbing on to his
leg this year is a throwaway year they
didn't make the playoffs
yo that's over now you're really not
sure what you got with the young guys
the rumor mill is a churning
anthony davis potentially landing with
la sometime
in the near future a player like this i
roll the dice and wait to the summer
what are the lakers i don't know what
they were trying to do
you can't try to make the playoffs and
develop your young guys
clearly we can't keep them all so we're
trying to sign a max
guy this summer rob has work to do magic
has work to do and lebron has work to do
next year we're not taking this nonsense
my only goal being here is to get the
lakers back
to playing championship basketball and
competing for a championship
that's my goal anthony davis traded to
the los
angeles lakers what does that do for the
balance of power out west
you got lebron you got a.d you're in the
conversation
i think the most difficult part for me
was just not knowing
leave a city that i've been playing for
for seven years and then get to play
alongside
um you know lebron play for
organizations that's all about winning
um career winning winning championships
you know and that's the only goal the
lakers
and the clippers being this good at the
same time
as always the lakers were big brother
and clippers with little brother in la
and now we're seeing something [ __ ]
they already don't recognize us as a
so-called la team but
y'all try to overlook us again i think
the clippers are the best team in the
west
him and a.d they combine for 41 points
through the first three quarters they
only combined for two points in that
fourth quarter
at the end of the day i don't have to
recognize it and we're gonna make you
understand who we are
the battle of l.a we're gonna see how
it's won
energy is one of the most underrated
aspects of basketball
and i think this is too much for him
he's got to do it all the time
it's going to be a tough one lebron said
he's been tired of watching people play
with the throne play with his name say
he's not on top anymore
i think we're going to see him come out
with a lot of added motivation this year
he's got something to prove there were
people this summer more than ever
wondering if you were washed you made
the cleaners well here comes lebron
oh my goodness turns back the clock
throws it up to howard and howard with
the slam
james with a great tap dave lebron
james has put the lakers in front
lebron to the rim what a fantastic
driving
i mean it just you know i'm a fan of
true greatness in sports i don't care
what team
what sport yes sir
wow
there's james goes across the lane lays
it up and lays it in and there it is he
just became
the third leading scorer in nba history
passing kobe bryant another milestone
for the great lebron james
i'm happy just to be in any conversation
with kobe being brian
as i got drafted i still just admired
him you know seeing what he was able to
accomplish winning championships
just admiring him for so many years it's
just too much the story is just too much
now i'm here in the lakers uniform in
philadelphia
kobe bryant is is dead at the age of 41
due to a helicopter crash
near calabasas california just north of
los angeles
it's too soon i mean way too soon
this was the guy they grew up on a true
iconic guy obviously the nba is reacting
to this news as
as we are right now
[Music]
i look at this as a celebration tonight
tonight we celebrate
the kid that came here at 18 years of
age
[Music]
retired at 38 and became
probably the best dad we've seen over
the last three years man
so in the words of kobe bryant
mamba out but in the words of us
not forgotten live on brother
number 24 and number eight
so he's a legend legends never died you
know we got to continue to push forward
because that's what he wanted to
the greatest do in the world today
lebron james the king
ten assists in five boards james
he got it
[Applause]
[Applause]
here's lebron trying to force his way in
he does
james gets in the pain and finishes not
an area where he excels at just
63 as james gets it go
james again matthew's trying to stay
with him
james inside banks that one in
foul and one rolls around and drops
through
james james spins and throws it down
lieutenant cooper the bucks lose for the
tenth time this season
i think the clippers are the best team
in the west the battle of l.a
james fouled counted and
pass inside james to davis reggie
jackson
comes up with a loose ball goes inside
reverse blocked by james
it's the largest lead here in the first
half james draws a foul
or strength again kawhi leonard guarding
lebron james
drives past him layup is good this
building is filled with laker jerseys
james drives land count it and the foul
lebron james putting on the finishing
touches
the game has been postponed between the
jazz and the thunder tonight still
awaiting
official word from the league office as
to exactly why they've determined not to
play tonight
we've been reading about this dealing
with this talking about this for the
last 2-3 weeks so
it's finally hit our country when i
think about who's going to win the
championship
what scared me about the guys going back
to play is injuries
when lebron sat down what are the lakers
going to be able to do
this plague of racism which comes at the
same time as this pandemic
demands our attention this is systematic
some of the injustice that we've been
seeing is not
okay would you like any water
we are living in a time now where
conversations that are difficult
but are necessary
the nba and the nvpa released an update
the nba returns
july 30th in orlando in a bubble
the rules are for everybody it's a
championship it's a championship you go
to play you go to win